[Music]
you know what I think is something we
could all do without uh guilty pleasures
that's what I'm
saying I'm not saying you should stop
Malden not that you should not that you
should stop watching like reality TV if
you like reality TV I'm saying you
should stop feeling guilty for enjoying
reality TV why is it a guilty pleasure
if something gives you pleasure it's
pleasure why are we all apologizing like
I like Smashmouth sorry
I say if you love Smashmouth love
Smashmouth blast it from your
convertible with the roof down then
drive to
rehearsal because if you love Smashmouth
you're probably the lead singer of
Smashmouth so let's stop having guilty
pleasures but listen I understand
sometimes I'm embarrassed by Mine by my
guilty pleasures like recently I was
watching one of those uh VH1 kind of of
fluffy countdown shows you know like uh
I love all the
decades or top 190s of the80s hosted by
kmen Electra you know what I mean it's
fun it's just a bunch of comedians with
colorful backdrops telling me why 1984
was incredible just like he man was d
man you know what I mean it's a fun time
it almost hypnotizes you what's not to
love but then my friend who was hanging
out with me he walked into the room and
I reacted like he caught me jerking
it I was like someone's in
here I jerk off like
G okay I
don't wi I
don't not on the card I but I say that I
should have been proud I like VH1
countdown shows and jerking
it sometimes at the same time
it's hosted by Caron Electra that's what
they
want guilty pleasure